The general good experience. It's so funny to me,
how people just get so caught up in East coast and West coast.
Cause it really only happened at rap. It never happened with rock and roll.
Right. You know, it never happened with sports. I mean,
it did a little bit with sports in some teams, but with the big thing with,
with rap music was always East coast versus West coast until you guys came here.
Right? Yeah.
I'm like really familiar with that beef. Uh,
I wrote about it in my book of how me and puffy,
you know, had a meeting and uh,
they wanted me to mediate a meeting with him and shook was concerned,
you know, with that was after Tupac and all of these people,
you know, had got killed and, uh,
it was something that I wanted to do, but I couldn't really get, you know, uh,
between it because you know, things just didn't add up properly.
And I don't believe in stepping in between something and when I don't have all
the information.
Mm yeah. That's gotta be extremely difficult. Right.
You were in the middle of like a legitimate war where
two of the all time greats yeah. Were murdered.
Yeah. I was asked to, uh, be in the middle of it. And then,
um, after Tupac was murdered, um,
one of the things I'd done was I heard puffy and biggie was in LA
shooting a video. So I was on my tour bus and I turned it all the way around.
I think I was close to Phoenix and I turned it around just to go and have a
conversation with big and puffy to alert them that they were in a place
that I didn't feel that they should have been in. And, you know,
I went there and had a conversation with both of them just to kind of put them
on, notice that, you know, this ain't the place to be. Right.
No, that was before biggie was killed. Yeah. How long before it was.
I think a few weeks, like a few weeks before and uh,
you know, sometimes, and I know puff, it meant well, and I know biggie mean,
well, sometimes a lot of individuals are what I call surface deep
where the streets are concerned, which simply mean you don't,
you understand them to a certain depth, you know what I mean?
But I understood that that wasn't definite LA,
that wasn't a good place to be because my ears was to the street
and you know, I just wanted to echo it.
It was on my spirit to let them know and I did.
And uh, unfortunately, you know, it didn't save him,
but everybody can learn from those mistakes moving forward.
The devastating loss, the both of them. Yeah.
I mean what they left behind, you know, to this day. Yeah.
If you got a Mount Rushmore of hip hop, those two dudes are on there. Right.
There's no doubt about it. Oh yeah. Two brilliant guys. Brilliant. Yeah.
There's a video of biggie on the street that I watch all the time when he was 17
years old piece of paper in his hand was lyrics. Yeah.
Rapping his off at 17 years old. Yeah. It's incredible.
When you watch the video, he was like, what talent? Yeah.
What power that dude had catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for
free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.